الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الان وفي
جديد ازمه الوثائق السريه التي تطارد
الرئيس جو بايدن كشفت ولفيت جورنال عن ان
وزاره العدل نظرت بالفعل في افريقيا عملاء
الاف بي اي بمراقبه عمليات تفتيش محامين
رئيس عن الوثائق السريه لكنها تراجعت وسبب
هو تجنب تعقيد المراحل اللاحقه من التحقيق
خاصه وان محامي بايدا تعاونوا وهم من
سلموا دفعه الاولى التي تم اكتشافها بسرعه
لجهه المعنيه ولد المحامين الشخصيين
تصاريح امنيه للتعامل مع الوثائق السريه
وتنحيه اي موده تصنف تحتها هذا البنك كان
المستشار الخاص لبيض هو الذي رافق موظفي
وزاره العدل الاسترداد الوثائق بعد اكتشاف
صفحات اضافيه بعلامات التصنيف
لكن وبالعوده الى المحامين الخاصين ببيضن
كيف يمكن تركهم بمفردهم في مهمه حساسه
كهذه يوضح المدعي الفيدراليه السابق
لنيوزنيشن ان بعض المحامين الحاضرين في
عمليات البحث لا يعملون شخصيا لصالح بيضا
حتى لو كانوا من موظفي البيت الابيض ويشرح
ان مجموعتين من المحامين شاركت في التفتيش
الاول في التفتيش الاولي من مكتب مستشار
البيت الابيض وهم مدنيون او مدينون بواجب
الحكومه الامريكيه وليس لجوبايدن كشخص اذا
هم مدينون بواجبهم لصالح الحكومه وليسوا
مدنين لجوبايدن كشخص ولذا فانهم حين
يكتشفون شيئا ما يتصرفون كعملاء بمكتب
التحقيقات الفيدرالي قد يكون هذا الشرح
بطبيعه الحال المقنعه لانصار بايضا لكنه
بالتاكيد غيره مقنع لانصار ترامب الذين
يتمسكون باتهام وزاره العدل بازدواجيه
المعايير في كل الاحوال التحقيقات في اولى
خطواتها بعد تعيين مدعام مستقل للتحقيق في
هذه الامه لكن ماذا حدث في اخر قضايا
مماثله خلال تحقيق المدعي العام المستقل
روبرت مولر الذي نذكره جميعا في تدخل
روسيا في حمله 2016 وعن مدى وجود روابط
بينها وحمله ترامب في الانتخابات حاول
المحققون لاكثر من عام اجراء مقابله مع
رئيس ترامب قبل ان يقبلوا في النهايه
بشهاده مكتوبه محامي بيدن رفض الاجابه عما
اذا كان الرئيس سيقبل باجراء مقابله مع
المدعي العام المستقل لكن حتى تصل الامور
الى هذا الحد هناك امر اخر يراهن عليه
انصار بايضا لانهاء الملف التقادم ناديه
البلبيسي
لا تزالوا قضيه وثائق بيض تلقي بظلال
قائمه على البيت الابيض لكن هنا في وزاره
العدل الان تحقيق لا يزال مستمرا لكن
محامي عامل مع فريقه وترجيت الذي ادى الى
استقاله الرئيس روتشرد نيكسون يرى بان
بيضا قد ينجو من ملاحظه قضائيه تجربه بسبب
مرور الوقت على حيازه هذه الوثائق فهي
تعود لي فتره حكم بيض عندما كان نائبا
للرئيس والقانون يضبط هذه الفتره بحوالي
خمس سنوات لكن بعيدا قد لا ينجو من مساء
الى في الكونجرس وملاحقه من الاعلام بسبب
غياب الشففي